and Ohio town is ringing in the holiday
season early this year for a very
special cause hundreds of people outside
Cincinnati held a Christmas celebration
yesterday for two-year-old Brodie Allen
the boy's parents learned last month
that their son's rare brain cancer has
spread
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn visited Brody's hometown
where the community delivered some
much-needed holiday cheer you come home
at night and the whole street is like
what up and it's it's amazing to know
that it's all for buddy
the season of giving is already underway
in one Cincinnati suburb on Sunday
two-year-old Brody Allen celebrated
Christmas he threw candy the crowds of
people wearing Santa hats and waving
signs Merry Christmas
last month Brody's parents Shiloh and
Todd learned their son's brain cancer
had advanced and that he only had two
months to live they go through all the
questions like you know we can radiation
radiation will just destroy him because
he's two clinical trials they couldn't
look for but it won't really give us any
more time I wanted to bring him home
during a difficult night Todd played an
old black-and-white version of Rudolph
the red-nosed reindeer for Brody on his
phone he actually fell asleep in it
calmed him watching him enjoy that
moment I was like okay but we're gonna
do Christmas the Allens decided to
celebrate Christmas in September they
turned to Facebook to ask neighbors for
help and the community responded
neighbors put up lights Santa's and snow
globes on their front lawn do you think
about the idea that wouldn't it be great
if everybody treated each other like
this anything day the time I think they
do we just don't see it I love Brody I
really do but the support didn't stop
there it has just been beautiful
Christmas card started arriving at the
Allen home what is this all done for you
all as a family it's a renewed my faith
and humanity and people Brody is one of
six kids
Mackenzie Allen is his oldest sister he
doesn't know that he's sake it for him
just a normal day you're the ones that
are in a way suffering perhaps even more
than he is
he carries everybody else he keeps us
keeps us in a good mood and this
community kept Brodie happy on a warm
autumn day by making it a very Merry
Christmas for CBS this morning
vladimir duthiers cincinnati ohio that's
a strong community it is that does that
mean less we bowling together